I'm keeping a list of books I want to read. Realistically, this would probably
have 50 items in it, but right now I'll keep it short. I'll start reading again
when you're writing your own programs from scratch in Java. Let's say there are
six books in my list to read for now. I'll store them as strings in an array
list, so they would be indexed like this. For now I'll store them as strings to
make this exercise less typing, but if I were doing this for real, I would
probably make a book class, so I could store authors and my friend who
recommended the book to me. Now a friend just recommended that I read Why
Zebras Don't Get Ulcers. I've decided that I want to read it after I read Night
Watch but before I read Next. What would method should I use to insert Why
Zebras Don't Get Ulcers after Night Watch and before Next without removing
anything from the list?